los resultados finales de las elecciones
parlamentarias anticipadas en armenios
fueron anunciados hace tan solo unas
horas antes con la marcada victoria del
partido oficialista del primer ministro
interino nico el pajín al que no obtuvo
casi el 54% de los votos por otro lado
la coalición armenia encabezada por el
ex presidente robert kocharián se
posicionó en el segundo lugar con 21 por
ciento de los votos y ante esto denunció
la posibilidad del disfraz de en el
proceso electoral este final fue
realmente sorpresivo especialmente si
tenemos en cuenta los resultados
arrojados en las encuestas previas que
en muchas ocasiones anunciaban el
triunfo de la coalición armenia en estas
elecciones participó alrededor de un 49
por ciento de la población empadronada y
en un contexto de intensa polarización
social los ánimos de los ciudadanos
varían entre la alegría y el descontento
o la angustia
es importante tener en cuenta que uno de
los puntos de mayor cuestionamiento a
esta reelección es la política exterior
que llevaría adelante el primer ministro
nicole pajín al especialmente las
relaciones que tejería con turquía con
azerbaiyán como así también con rusia
por el momento hoy el primer ministro
interino a nicole para gillian convocó a
los ciudadanos a una concentración para
celebrar esta victoria en la plaza de la
república de yereván